underworld goddess is a tied bat and an
adventurous pet pig who joins our
heroine on her quest for all chopped
from the final version of Moana new PK
movie lovers it's Jan here and in this
video I want to talk about some of the
fascinating deleted scenes characters
and rejected concepts that didn't make
it into the final film of mallanna I've
also got a second copy of this amazing
authors Moana hardback book by Abrams
and chronicles to give away to a lucky
winner on this video the book is chock
full of gorgeous concept art and info on
Disney's animated feature and for a
chance to win a copy all you have to do
is subscribe and leave a comment about
the deleted scenes or story changes on
this video and don't forget there are
bonus ways to enter the giveaway by the
gleam link in the video description
below as you can imagine I'll be
discussing spoilers in this video so if
you're not ready for those grab the
nearest canoe out of here by clicking
the screen for my spoiler free review of
lo mo the beginning of the movie changed
quite considerably over the course of
the one as developments with a number of
scenes that feed to the lengthy of
backstories Moana being deleted so let's
start with toddler Moana who had one of
the movie's most beautiful scenes when
she first discovered the ocean and the
heart of defeating originally to balance
that moment out there was going to be a
much darker scene included in the film
as well in that deleted scene a very
young Moana walks out into the ocean
during a storm and tries to control it
but the ocean knocked her off a rock a
Moana nearly drowns until her father
chief to e rescued her
although that scene was cut in the final
movie there is a similar moment of
danger when an older Moana is
shipwrecked after trying to sail beyond
the reef with kueh another cutscene with
the young Moana shows her on a boat
together with her father in the scene
Moana questions why they only travel
between the same three islands when
there's a whole ocean to explore she's -
he claims that past the horizon is the
edge of nowhere and the everything
beyond it was consumed by a land spirit
calls to PO which by the way was the
movie's original name for the lava demon
to carve during that deleted scene we
also get to see a sweet moment between
rowana and the piglet puah who she
decides to adopt as her pet pig as he
isn't feeding from his mother with the
rest of his litter in fact in earlier
scripts that very cute and lovable
Kunekune II pig was going to
join mallanna on her adventure however
as the story develops the filmmakers
decided it would be funnier and better
for the story if Moana ended up stuck
with a stupid rooster out on the ocean
rather than her lovable friend kruer
speaking of that dumb rooster hey hey
his character was actually although
scratched in the film entirely he was
originally conceived as a type of watch
dog who would keep an eye on the whine
of a chief tui in a role that was
similar to how the crab Sebastian from
The Little Mermaid kept watch on Ariel
for her father Triton
however hey hey just wasn't working in
the story draft and was in serious
danger of being cooked completely when
Disney chief creative officer John
Lasseter gave the script writers two
days to find a new role for him in the
end hey hey was gunned down massively
and turned into a rooster that like to
swallow Rock and the scene whether
Kimura attacked Moana and Maui to steal
the heart of the city was rewritten to
have hey hey complicate the situation
further by swallowing the gem making the
crazy roof to the center of the action
by the way when John Lasseter decided
that hey hey could remain in the movie
the team celebrated with a special meal
of fried chicken and there were quite a
few other changes and deleted scenes
that affected the set of Huaraz story
one idea was that Moana would have to
set sail in order to rescue her father
who got lost at sea although this
storyline was rejected an element of it
remained in chief - his backstory in
particular the part about how he lost
his friend at sea one day which became
the reason why you wouldn't let Moana go
beyond the reef and chief QE sphere of
voyaging was further explored in a
cutscene where he argued with grandma
Tala about why Moana shouldn't risk her
life by sailing beyond the reef in the
final movie this difference of opinion
between grandma Tyler and her son Timmy
plays out quite differently only being
touched upon briefly when he interrupts
grandma Tala after her scary tale of
Maui and defeat II at the start of the
film in another version of the movie
Moana has six brothers and there was a
scene cut where she raced a group of
them to prove to her father that she was
the best sailor of them all in the scene
chief - he isn't impressed however and
refuses to take the one on the journey
is planning to defeat II as he says it's
too dangerous
although it's a fun scene with Moana
performing lots of cool maneuvers to
outrace her siblings the merely feels
better for leaving out her brothers and
this storyline
what's refreshing about the final film
is that the story doesn't just trot out
the well-worn cliche of a girl or woman
having to prove she's just as good as
the boys or men around her to be taken
even semi seriously in the final version
of the movie Moana automatically has
respect from her father and her
community who naturally assume that in
time she will become the chief of her
Island so by scrapping the brother
characters Moana didn't have to battle
sexist attitudes to succeed in her quest
by the way there was also an alternate
ending to mana where she didn't just
have six brothers but nine brothers all
of whom she needed to rescue as they
were being held hostage another deleted
scene at Moana sailing shows that she
was already a very skilled sailor before
she embarked on her journey the scene
was cut because the filmmakers decided
that if Moana had to learn to sail from
Maui it would provide more opportunities
for humor and development between the
parents by the way this deleted scene
also offers a little peek at hey hey
acting more like the jerky was in his
earlier incarnations rather than the
dumb rooster his character was later
reworked to be the realm of monsters aka
leather tie or the underworld featured
numerous scenes stories and characters
that sadly didn't make it into the final
film in one early version Maui had to
enter lullaby in disguise as he had
enemies that lived in the underworld
and is actually a little nod to this
idea in the final movie when the line
addresses of his bait to distract Tama
Toa while Maori recovered his fish hook
it was also a deleted character called
Hina who guarded the entrance another
time Hina would have been Mary's
grandmother in the movie and in
Polynesia mythology she the heroic
goddess and companion to Maui mini Maui
is a great comedic character in Moana
but initially he was going to feature a
lot less in the story however it was
actually a scene that ended up being
deleted from the movie that was crucial
to mini Maui getting more screen time in
the final film in the deleted scene Maui
jumps down into the underworld and gets
hit by a large rock then when he checks
on mini Maui he discovers that a little
nodding tattoo is unconscious maui tries
to wake him up with mouth-to-mouth
resuscitation which leads to many Maori
springing back to life spluttering and
disgusted when the scene was tested
internally at Disney it has such a good
response that it led to many Maori
getting a lot more scenes in the movie
even though that particular moment ended
up on the cutting room floor also
removed from the underworld scenes was
an encounter Moana had with her
ancestors you helped her with the
emotional struggle she was having on her
journey a different version of this
rejected scene appears in the final film
when Moana has a crisis of confidence
after she and Maui initially failed to
restore the heart to car and Maui
abandoned her the spirit of grandma's
holla and her seafaring for birds then
appear to Moana singing the song with
the ancestors which gives strength to
our heroine who finishes a scene with a
powerful rendition of I am Moana there's
also a scene that was cut to time when
Moana and Maui have to get past an a tie
fad called water the wicked on their way
to reach Tama Toa the duo use a pair of
conch shell to distract and confuse the
creature while they get past it looks
like there might have been an easter
eggs the little mermaid Sebastian in
this scene as Maui pulls out a little
red crab from the shell he's been using
by the way the 8id bat creature Moana
originates from Polynesian legends of
Maui carrying a giant a tied bat that
tried to steal Mary's wife cool armor
concept art and storyboards the lava tie
also reveal a type of yellow brick roads
that Maui and Moana would have followed
on the journey to cavitus lair and just
before Moana and Maui meet Tammy TOA who
is a deleted song they would have
performed called warrior face in the
song Maui and Moana hiked themselves up
for their confrontation with a
villainous giant crab the song was
written by lin-manuel Miranda and was
based on the Polynesian traditional
hacker dance it didn't make it into the
final film as the directors felt it
showed Moana and Maui's bonding too
early the storyboarded scene shows that
if the song had been included it would
have been an opportunity for a fantastic
montage of many other more strange and
wonderful creatures than we already saw
in the movie final version of the
underworld but that wasn't the only song
deleted from the film there was another
cut song about The Legend of Maui it was
called unstoppable and combined elements
of grandmas hollered opening story and
Maui song you're welcome
by the way before the shiny collecting
obsessed Krab Tama Toa became part of
the film earlier scripts featured a
headless warrior character who collected
things was based on an oceanic myth
however of course the headless warrior
didn't speak so the Phil
has decided to combine his character
with a giant crab character - again in
earlier scripts was going to attack
Moana and Maui at sea and that's how
stammer Toa as we know him today in
order fling eNOS was born
initially the Camorra weren't as
aggressive as they turned out to be in
the final film and they weren't little
coconut villains either instead they
were originally based on oceanic legends
the Camorra who is short hairy
mischievous Hobbit light beings and
according to head of story David
Pimentel
ikkaku mora and murano are going to be
little party animals however because the
filmmakers wanted them to pose a real
threat Samoa now they made them much
scarier an inspiration for their design
came from the war boys in the movie Mad
Max fury road perhaps the craziest
concept that was rejected by the movies
team with a story about a time-traveling
Moana Moana as we know it is actually
set around 2,000 years ago within the
time-traveling version of the movie
Moana was a modern girl who travels back
in time and mecha ancestors now what do
you think about the deleted scenes and
characters are there any you would have
loved have seen in the movie make sure
you comment and subscribe for your
chance to win this amazing hardback book
the awesome Moana and if you enjoyed
this video do please like and share it
and turn on your notifications of flicks
in the city to stay up to date click or
tap below to watch more Disney deleted
scenes or more of my Moana videos
including how Maui's story almost ruined
Moana thanks for watching and see you
next time
yippee-ki-yay movie lovers